tastes like childhood popularity I mean
the reason why I've never had a
lunchable is so late because my parents
were just like very cheap at growing up
my parents just didn't buy me any of
that's like cool kid food that my
friends ate and like cereal and stuff
there was just like the status quo that
like if you had Lunchables you were cool
so I was wondering if that's a thing I
only heard of him a couple of weeks ago
people is so hype here with him that
yeah they're like a big deal yeah we
definitely didn't have Lunchables in
rush things and boxes we don't trust oh
my god Pizza I love this oh she has the
pizza one is it frozen that's like the
one I always wanted I got that I got
that crackers one no I don't want cheese
and crackers chicken dung I feel like
they need to rethink the name a little
bit I don't know I feel like I'm back in
score I'm like do you want a swap
it's a meat Mogis mold I don't know I
don't like I don't like it when I can
let down my food up side yeah it's like
still normal or comic hole is pretty
cool these two animals go into a pet
store to check it out and then they walk
off with callers around their necks and
I quote goes that didn't turn out the
way I thought so we got four little four
little nugget chips do you go hand
Sisson cheese or cheese and then hand
tiny pizza it doesn't taste bad though
it just tastes kind of like cheese and
crackers it's like if mashed potatoes
was flavored like chicken the sauce is
so good I like it tastes like tomato
sauce are you supposed to microwave
these things am I missing something
I really thought there's a cosmic
brownie involved what is it it's like a
juice yeah you know like a making a good
old lunch table trade I think like the
red sauce would have been a hazard to my
clothing as a child I have to ask myself
like is it weird or is it because I'm
Indian and I'm not from here I need a
primary school and probably be quite
satisfied if I was younger but as an
adult I think I'd want like a hot slice
of pizza I would have a tantrum and need
it now this would be so dope
if you were like 2:00 in the morning
when you're really drunk and you're
really hungry you're like you
dry mouth it has some capri-sun mmm
slowly don't vomit eat some tiny cheese
and crackers it feels like such an
American school experience that I'm like
now I feel special ish for one of them
no I don't need you don't put in the
microwave on things is it Pizza cold
then yeah you're cold and pretty sure
there's a negative role Pizza mmhmm yeah
[Music]